[Applaudissements]
ce soir j'aimerais partager avec vous l'
aventure de l'engagement à travers mon
histoire mes premiers pas depuis tout
petit en fait je sais ce que je veux
faire je voulais être humanitaire en
fait à six ans je crois que je savais
pas trop ce que ça voulait dire et
pourquoi je voulais être humanitaire
peut-être que c'était l'affluence du
passé résistante de ma grand mère ou les
missions en afrique de mon père mais
lorsque j'avais 8 ans je me souviens
qu'on avait écrit un journal avec des
copines ça s'appelait le quotidien des
girls on est étroit et il y avait
sandrine qui elle nous expliquer comment
choisir la petite robe noire pour la
prochaine boom et il y avait aussi fanny
qui l écrivait plutôt des articles du
type comment rouler une pelle à un
garçon pour la première fois et puis
j'avais mes articles 6 et mois pour
écrire mes articles bah j'avais lu tout
ce que je pouvais lire sur la guerre en
bosnie en ce moment là sur le vih ces
thèmes et sujets j'avais écrit quatre
pages j'avais lu des bouquins regarder
la télé à ce moment-là à huit ans mes
parents il était un peu inquiet je sais
pas si c'était grave je m'en rendais pas
trop content mais en tout cas chez que
pour moi c'est là que tout a commencé
à 21 ans j'entrais chez médecins du
monde pour mon premier stage
et puis à 23 ans je m'envolais au
honduras pour ma première mission là-bas
partir là bas pour leur apprendre à se
développer confie s'il disait que quand
un homme a faim mieux vaut lui apprendre
à pêcher que lui donner du poisson
en fait ça fait des centaines d'années
que les gens ils pêchent
ils ont pas du tout besoin de nous pour
leur apprendre alors je me suis demandé
pourquoi l'humanitaire ça existe et les
poissons bien sûr c'est des images
en fait c'est nos emplois nos magasins
nos services publics
encadrés par nos gouvernements des
gouvernements qui parfois dans une
certaine situation ça peut être un
ouragan une guerre civile
ils peuvent plus faire face ils peuvent
plus assurer leur rôle premier de prise
en charge de leur population en france
souvent on oublie ce que c'est les
services publics tout ce que cela
comprend c'est notre enseignement c'est
la culture c'est notre santé c'est
l'environnement
tous ces services pour l'essentiel
gratuit financé par nos impôts
est-ce que vous avez une idée de combien
coûte une journée d'hospitalisation en
france par exemple en service de
cancérologie
c'est entre 1600 et 2000 200 euros la
journée
ça correspond au salaire moyen d'un
français à ce moment là j'ai compris
pourquoi les services publics existent
j'ai aussi compris pourquoi des ong dans
certaines situations prenez le relais
des gouvernements et j'ai eu envie de
commencer à faire un pas puis un pas de
plus en travaillant dans différents
contextes
ça a été lent prises des
narcotrafiquants en amérique centrale la
guerre syrienne ces peuples sans droit
et sans terre qui parfois pour certains
voient naître la troisième génération
dans des camps de réfugiés comme dans le
désert algérien où la bande de gaza
hier c'était la crise roaring à ce
groupe ethnique a fui a bien manié vers
le bangladesh
suite à des persécutions lorsque
j'arrive sur place c'est un flot de
femmes et d'enfants
la plupart des hommes ont été massacrés
cd on dit auquel je fais face mais avec
les autorités locales et les autres ong
on essaye d'installer le plus rapidement
possible des camps pour répondre à leurs
besoins
le besoin basique de chaque être humain
boire manger dormir s'instruire se laver
être soigné et cet être humain ça
pourrait être vous ça pourrait être moi
mais moi à ce moment-là je suis du bon
côté et je peux participer à rendre leur
présente plus supportable pour pouvoir
ré envisager demain et que ça soit au
bangladesh ou agos beïda à la frontière
entre le tchad et le sud soudan les
journées s'enchaînent
ça n'arrête pas et j'adore ça je sais
pourquoi je suis là
parfois quand tu travailles dans des
contextes de crise tu prends aussi des
risques
c'est une réalité pour toi pour ton
équipe
parfois on analyse le contexte de
sécurité toutes les quatre heures on se
force à se rappeler que un mort c'est
toujours moins efficace qu'un vivant et
à ce moment là je fais juste confiance
on mélange d'instinct m sang froid qui
s'est développée progressivement avec
les années c'est ainsi que pendant dix
ans petit à petit j'ai avancé de plus en
plus assuré et puis à chaque retour de
mission je rentrais en france et je
retrouvais ma bande de copains c'était
ma base à moi mon équilibre
ce sont des grimpeurs des alpinistes des
belges ont peur tous ces sports de
nature qu'on dit extrêmement eux aussi
la prise de risque ils savent ce que
c'est ils savent ce que c'est de tomber
de se relever de parfois être épuisé
après avoir tout donné ils connaissent
ce mélange de sincérité émotionnel et
d'honnêteté intellectuelle pour lâcher
prise et pouvoir s'engager au bon moment
comme on devrait le faire en fait pour
chaque acte pour chaque rencontre
et c'est justement ce que j'ai fait il
ya un an quand j'ai rencontré à roanne
aaron hill et guides de haute montagne
il a plusieurs vies lui aussi mais en
fait si je vous dis la vérité ça fait
pas un an que j'ai racontée à roanne ça
fait 15 ans il faisait partie de cette
bande de copains mais il ya un an
il m'a dit moi alors sérieusement c'est
quand qu'on travaille ensemble
ce n'était pas la première fois qu'il
m'en parler mais cette fois j'ai dit oui
à cette aventure professionnelle comme
j'ai dit oui à ma première mission
humanitaire et dire oui à erwan s'était
pas n'importe quelle aventure
professionnelle s'était embarqué sur
maïwenn maïwenn
c'est une fabuleuse expédition de 7 ans
de l'arctique à l'antarctique en passant
par le pacifique à bord d'un voilier
ces temps où avec des sportifs de haut
niveau on va à la rencontre de personnes
d'acteurs pour les aider à réaliser un
pas que ce soit leurs premiers pas ou un
pas de plus alors quand je vous dis
s'étend de l'arctique à l'antarctique
vous imaginez pas que maïwenn c'est un
gros en yacht il fait 10 mètres 80 c'est
petit et quand on va passer le cap horn
je pense qu'on va se faire démonter on
sera en autres coques de noix et à
l'interdire 1 2 my one c'est open space
erwan il a retiré les portes les douches
les toilettes il fallait gagner de la
place pour le matériel technique notre
carré central
à l'intérieur c'est à la fois notre
salon notre cuisine notre chambre
notre home cinéma notebart suivant nos
besoins et nos envies
à l'extérieur le pont c'est notre
terrasse avec l'océan comme jardin et
grâce à maïwenn pour la première fois on
peut transporter notre maison sur le dos
comme un escargot avec sakho
qui pour aller à la rencontre des
peuples tout en partageant nos univers
on est dans un véritable échange
car notre objectif à bord de maïwenn
c'est d'accompagner ces personnes qu'on
raconte cet automne avec nathan et anto
on était en polynésie à tahiti et on a
accompagné 20 jeunes de l'association
sos villages d'enfants en les aidant à
réaliser à construire leur projet
pendant 20 jours
on a essayé d'identifier quels étaient
leurs passions leurs rêves
on a décortiqué avec eux l'impossible
pour le rendre atteignable c'était
complètement ouf de voir leur visage et
un premier jour s'illuminer petit à
petit à chaque fois composer une pierre
à leur projet demain on partira avec
mathilde chercheuse et denis réaliste 2
apnéistes pour faire une recherche pour
réaliser une websérie sur les pratiques
de pêche
parce qu'être abords de maïwenn c'est un
peu comme être à bord d'une mini terre
où les ressources sont limitées et donc
partagés et donc grâce à cette série
nous aimerions faire prendre conscience
des différentes pratiques de pêche avec
les pêcheurs les associations locales
des gouvernements les ministères pour
trouver un espace de discussion et
d'action sur cette gestion de nos
ressources
alors le travail que demande la
réalisation de ses rêves est gigantesque
parfois on est inquiet on ne sait jamais
si la prochaine vague qui arrivera nous
détrompera où nous permettra de surfer
sur de nouveaux horizons
mais on garde toujours à leit motiv
constant faire face aux difficultés pour
les utiliser comme tremplin sans jamais
oublier l'objectif qu'on s'était fixés
alors ce soir
des histoires je pourrais vous a raconté
des centaines je pourrais vous raconter
des histoires magnifiques des drôles des
plus compliqués mais ce que j'avais
vraiment envie de partager avec vous ce
soir c'était le courage de faire ce pas
tall pas de partir à l'autre bout du
monde
mais le pas qui nous permet de nous
rapprocher de nous mêmes parce que s'il
ya bien quelque chose en quoi je crois
c'est que nous avons tous des parcours
extraordinaire et nous avons tous la
capacité de faire ce pas vous savez pour
tous les personnes du tedx qui viennent
de passer ça n'a pas été facile de faire
ce pas on a eu peur on a douté on était
en colère et on a un an de données nous
avons dû faire le point sur nous mêmes
sur d'où nous venions où nous sommes où
nous allons aller en toute sincérité
dans notre coeur dans notre corps est
dans notre tête on a dû demander de
l'aide et accepté d'en recevoir
mais maintenant c'est tellement bon
d'avoir fait ce pas une boîte là avec
vous que j'aimerais que vous
réfléchissiez ce soir en rentrant à quel
tas vous pourrez faire demain dans tout
le monde des possibles que nous offre
notre planète
merci
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]